el reino unido- se sumó a las voces de
rechazo y condena internacional por el
asesinato hoy del presidente de haití
job en el móvil en su comparecencia de
todos los miércoles en el parlamento
británico el primer ministro boris
johnson calificó este hecho como
abominable las informaciones que se
conocen hasta el momento es que el
presidente fue asesinado dentro de su
propia casa esta madrugada -hora local-
de haití en esta comparecencia boris
johnson dijo además de estar
conmocionado y triste y llamó a la calma
en medio de la tensión en ese país
caribeño considerado uno de los más
pobres del mundo
johnson además envió un sentido mensaje
de condolencias para la familia del
presidente pero también para todos los
haitianos pero algo de lo más importante
para resaltar de esta comparecencia de
boris johnson esta declaración en el
parlamento es un llamado a la calma en
este momento